I've eaten dessert virtually every night
for 20 years I have never skipped
dessert and I've been able to maintain a
six-pack for that entire period of time
I have done a lot of different diet keto
stuff I've done high carb I've done low
carb I've done high fat I've done
intermittent fasting alternate day
fasting carnivore style eating whatever
the last 10 years I've pretty much eaten
the exact same way be able to have
business dinners be able to have drinks
many of the entrepreneurs that I know
who've seen me eat and been around me a
long time end up adopting this and they
never go back what I'm not saying is
this is the most scientifically
researched whatever I'm just sharing
work for me if something works for you
just keep doing that number one is you
have to figure out what your goal is
either trying to get bigger you're
trying to get smaller from there you
start at number seven all the way up to
21. my videographers will put it right
here 7 to 21 and every three you go from
Extreme Weight Loss to moderate weight
loss to maintenance to moderate weight
gain to extreme weight gain all you have
to do is multiply your body weight so
I'm going to use 200 pounds as my
average because it's easy with math so
let's say I'm a 200 pound guy and I want
to get leaner I'm going to go to
moderate cut which is the second from
the bottom here of these three which
you've got 10 11 12 and I'm going to say
10 because it's easy math and so I'm
going to multiply 200 which is my weight
times 10 which is this coefficient which
gives me Dremel please 2 000 calories
all right now if you're like doesn't it
change what about my exercise and what
if I have a physical job it doesn't
really matter if you lose too much
weight too fast go to 11. you can adjust
it we've got 2 000 calories great here's
step three you multiply your weight 200
pounds again you multiply it by one
really hard math means 200 grams of
protein some of the science nerves are
gonna be like you can only metabolize
0.7 grams per don't give a every
pound of lean meat white fish ground
turkey breast 96 foreground beef shrimp
whatever a pound is a hundred grams of
protein so if you need 200 grams you
need two pounds and that's if you
exclusively ate meat I tend to eat over
my one gram per pound I like eating
protein it fills me up I feel good on it
that's why I do it if you don't need as
much don't now we're back to the math
this is the last math equation we're
going to do we have 2 000 calories and
we know we have to eat 200 grams of
protein all you have to do is figure out
what two pounds of meat you want to eat
or where you want to get your 200 grams
of protein from and figure out how many
calories are in that thing these two
pounds of meat are both turkey I eat
turkey for both meals crazy these are
both 560. I know that that's 11 20.
that's how many calories I have of
protein that I eat in my day so I
subtract my calories associated with
those meals from my 2000 in this example
and I would have 880 calories left over
those 880 calories here's the magic of
how this works you can do whatever you
want with them if you need to go out to
a business dinner you want to have
drinks cool well cocktail's probably 150
calories have two of those and have a
500 calorie meal of whatever you want
because again you've already got your
protein you could just stay at home and
have an entire pint of ice cream that's
880 calories or each of these cookies is
probably 400 calories you can have two
of them and that could be your dinner
and mind you that's with a cut that's
with me trying to lose a pretty
significant amount of weight now I
actually maintain because we're going to
this third chunk
right in this in this uh 13 to 15 chunk
If I multiply my body weight I'm more
than 200 but let's just say it's 200 for
Matt's sake times 15 3 000 calories so I
would have an extra thousand calories on
top of that thousand if I did that same
thing instead of having two of these
cookies I could have like five of these
cookies for dinner or I could have two
of these bites and still have some food
I eat the same breakfast and lunch every
day I start my day with let's call it a
200 calorie bar you call it a brownie it
doesn't matter if I'm traveling I might
not have this with me I'll grab a Quest
Bar at the airport right 200 calories
and 20 grams of protein one of those
bars and then I have a shake and this is
30 grams of protein and 160 calories I'm
in for 360 calories for my breakfast I
got 50 grams of protein knocked down
already then I go to my lunch I have a
pound of turkey which we already know is
560 and I actually only eat half of one
of these guys one cup of rice I now have
150 grams of protein and 1140 in terms
of calories that I've eaten so far mind
you I have 3 000 calories just to
maintain all right not bad so now I go
to dinner dinner is the big Flex meal
for me now I also tend to eat pound of
protein at dinner do I need to
absolutely not do I want to absolutely I
love eating protein I feel good when I
eat meat if you didn't let's say you
were 150 pounds and you'd already eaten
150 grams of protein at this point your
entire dinner could be whatever you want
pretty cool all right as long as it
equaled out to the total amount of
calories you want and I do this also
because then I'm full if I just eat
cookies
this has worked for a very long time I
actually had a couple of guys stop me
and say dude you made this nutrition
video and like I lost 50 pounds using it
like thanks so much I got a bunch of DMS
about this stuff and so this is really
what I eat every day so if you're like
where's your greens I have a
multivitamin and I continue to stay
alive and guys I stayed away from
Fitness stuff mostly because like
there's all these armchair debates and
like I just don't care if you want I can
do a part two on how I train as an
entrepreneur it's different than if you
were like a pro bodybuilder or a strong
man or a powerlifter or Olympic lifter
or just a normal gym rat I can make that
a second video put in the comments if
not just enjoy this one